now you will it I've read and I've seen
announcements to the effect of that you
will not read you will not be Batman
again I am yeah I have decided to no
thank you thank you very much yeah you
know I tried to direct a version of it
and worked with a really good
screenwriter but just kind of couldn't
come up with a version that couldn't
crack it and so I thought it was like
you know time to let someone else take a
shot at they got some really good people
song well I don't know if you know but
there's a ceremony and you know it
happens whenever the the bat torch is
passed and in honor of your I guess
retirement I don't know what we're gonna
call it I don't know you later
we have a little bit of a surprise for
you oh we Warner Brothers has given us
something we're going to officially
retire
[Applause]
[Music]
you dress right now
rubber no Robert anyway so but first we
have to make space in the rafters by
getting rid of another piece of
Hollywood memorabilia please lower the
thong this is this beautiful item is the
sparkly thong Matt Damon wore when he
played Liberace's boyfriend and behind
the candelabra yes please give this to
him or how to destroyed whatever you
want to do yeah Damon my bed yes all
right Guillermo get in position put it
in there and then wait a minute why does
your cape have hold on a second why does
your cape have a number 12 on it that's
that's Brady's number you can't be a
hero unless you're wearing number 12 who
is this like a post did you get this
after the Super Bowl
no I insisted to Warner Brothers that be
on it the whole time they actually paid
eighty million dollars to digitally
remove it from everywhere I had no idea
why you really love Tom Brady well
before we do this is there anything you
want to say any official statement you
would like to make uh I don't know I
guess I'm not Batman he's not Batman
anymore hoist the Cape raise it to the
rafters and Ben Affleck you are
[Applause]
[Music]
Circle frontier everybody is Charlie so
as you see Ben Affleck recently went on
Kimmel and explained what exactly is
going on with his version of Batman
there were a lot of questions after they
announced what was going on with Matt
Reeves version of the Batman so we'll
break it all down because now that we
know officially what's going on with Ben
Affleck's Batman there's sort of this
domino effect where it affects all the
other DC movies and future Justice
League movies there's a new round of
that Amazon giveaway - all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Batman moment on the video
I just broke this down top 7 style so
number 7 Ben Affleck is clarifying that
he will not be exercising the other two
films left on his Batman contract at
Warner Brothers No More Ben Affleck's
version of Batman in any future movie
pending some twist in like 10 years with
a flashpoint movie thomas wayne stunt
casting or Batman Beyond if they can't
get Michael Keaton or a much much older
a Christian Bale to come back in many
many years 6 because they don't have
Justice League 2 on the books for a long
long time that means that effectively
Matt Reeves Batman prequel movies still
working title quote-unquote the Batman
will truly be a self-contained franchise
in the DC Universe for the next several
years until if it's really successful
they decide to bring a trilogy forward
into present day with future sequels the
way that Wonder Woman 3 in Aquaman 2 are
set in present-day they've already
talked about Wonder Woman 3 even though
we haven't gotten Wonder Woman 1984 yet
for the most part DC movies with the
exception of the Batman prequel is going
to be set during present day so they can
still continue to crossover in potential
future Justice League sequels like even
the birds of prey movie is taking place
in present day after the events of
Justice League and Suicide Squad so a
lot of what happens with Batman in
future Justice League movies and who
that Batman might wind up being depends
on how successful Matt Reeves Batman
movie is speaking of self-contained
movies though number 5 talking about the
other side of this equation the Joker
saying goes for Todd Phillips Joker film
it was created with the intention
specifically that it be a one-off thing
Elseworlds not tied to the other
pre-existing DC movies around Justice
League a one-off origin story about the
Joker I don't even know that they have
sequels planned for that so if it does
really well
who knows what they're gonna do more
recently though the Joker as of rebirth
famously has three distinct origin
stories so think of his Joaquin Phoenix
Joker that way there were all still
valid origin stories and it also kind of
doesn't make sense in the way that the
Joker's character is always meant to be
portrayed is contradictory Christopher
Nolan and Heath Ledger nailed that
aspect of the character during the dark
night every time he would narrate his
backstory to one of his victims it would
change a little you want to know how I
got these scars and then he would tell a
slightly different version of what
happened to him for the main reason why
Ben Affleck is saying that he decided to
officially leave Batman before his
contract was up with Warner Brothers as
he says in this interview is mostly
because of what happened with his
version of the Batman movie not working
out with the studio he says he and
another screenwriter weren't able to
crack it but what I think that means is
is that one that other screenwriter was
Jeff Jones I don't know why he didn't
mention him by name in this video maybe
Jeff Jones before this happened just
personally asked him not to mention his
name on air like please just don't
mention me when you're talking about
Batman's stuff into I think his version
of the movie they wrote was probably
pretty cool but just totally and
creatively was not a story that Warner
Brothers was comfortable with like it's
not hard to make a Batman movie you
could make a really badass Batman movie
but if it's not where the studio wants
to take the character that's usually
where you have problems look at the
direction they're taking all the newest
movies creatively post Batman V Superman
and Justice League Aquaman
big bright huge action film Wonder Woman
1984 visually very different from the
first Wonder Woman movie which is still
sort of a relic of the Zack Snyder era
of DC films because it was pretty
Justice League in Zack Snyder did have a
lot to do with the making of that first
movie he was a producer on it I think he
also has a screenwriting credit on it as
well but the version of the Batman movie
that Ben Affleck was going to write
direct in Storen was supposed to be Joe
Manganiello Deathstroke as the main
villain and it was supposed to be the
raid redemption style movie where Batman
is forced to fight his way down level by
level through Arkham Asylum through his
rogues gallery of villains to get to who
knows what the thing about that ben
affleck geoff johns script is that we
never found out what the end of the
movie was supposed to be or why batman
had to fight his way through Arkham in
the first place like what was this all
about like it was just a really cool
pitch Batman
fighting his way through Arkham that
just sounds like a cool idea so
presumably when they pitched that idea
to Warner Brothers initially they were
probably like oh hell yeah that sounds
like a cool idea but then when they
brought them the final script
they either felt like it wasn't strong
enough or by that time Warner Brothers
had been like okay we need to push these
characters in a different direction so
remember Batman
during Batman V Superman the way he
moves sort of like the tone the colors
everything the Ben Affleck Jeff Jones
Batman script was probably more in that
vein and that's probably why Warner
Brothers is like no we kind of want to
go in a different creative direction
from that stuff or it's possible that
Warner Brothers saw the script it just
felt like it wasn't strong enough I mean
we'll never know until we actually read
that script so hopefully someday
somebody will leak it and we'll actually
get to read it or maybe we can get Kevin
Smith's to have a friendís anse with Ben
Affleck and get Ben Affleck on his
podcast and he can tell the entire story
of what his Batman movie was going to be
but number three with Ben Affleck
formerly out you also have the other
side of the equation Jared Leto if you
haven't heard the recent news Jared
Leto's Joker movies that reportedly two
of them that were in development are
also being shelved right now in the
character will not be featured in a
significant way in any more DC movies
like we're only a couple months away
from them officially saying oh yeah no
more Jared Leto Joker in any of these
movies but that means that he's not
gonna be featured in any of the harley
quinn movies which are sort of separate
from the Joker movies there was the
birds of prey and then there's the
Harley Quinn Mad Love film which I
believe was going to be centered on her
version of Harley Quinn and the Joker
the birds of prey movie that they just
announced we just got the teaser for
that that treats the characters as if
it's Harley Quinn just having left the
Joker if you ever remember the Gotham
City sirens style episodes from Batman
the Animated Series where Harley Quinn
tells Joker to screw off and she just
goes around town having fun with poison
ivy that sort of idea and if you're
wondering about Gotham City sirens and
some of those other female Batman
villains it sounds like they'll do them
in birds-of-prey sequels so whatever
happens in this first one it sounds like
that franchise is building towards the
Gotham City sirens crossover but
effectively that means the next time we
see the Joker in present-day continuity
Inadi
the movie it'll be some other new
version of the character with a new
actor that we have no idea about yet
they'll probably just tiptoe around that
during the birds of prey movie and just
not address it at all what that also
means though is is that they could wait
to introduce a new Joker during future
Matt Reeves Batman sequels if that movie
is successful and it should go without
saying that because no Ben Affleck
Batman in future DC movies that means
that that movie that was originally
supposed to be a flashpoint movie Batman
a big part of the flashpoint story is
definitely not going to happen in
whatever the flash movie is it'll be a
vastly different story the saga of the
flash movie is long and twisty just like
the saga of Ben Affleck's Batman number
2 the new version of Batman the new
direction that DC is taking him / Matt
Reeves is Detective neo-noir Batman set
near the Batman year one era of his
career now it's not exactly Batman year
one but I think in terms of his age
think of it as being set between the
events of Batman Begins in The Dark
Knight
he was already pretty badass by that
point and he was ready for a full-blown
Joker encounter so Matt Reeves Batman is
more accomplished than Batman Begins
Christian Bale like he's not brand new
but he hasn't quite got through his
comic book rogues gallery villains like
the Joker yet Matt Reeves did clarify
that there would be several Batman
villains during the film but I believe
the current rumor is is that the penguin
will be the main villain and it'll feel
like the story will feel more like
Batman mask of the phantasm if you
haven't seen that animated movie be sure
to watch it it is one of the best Batman
movies of all time it's on the DC
streaming service right now number one
though future of Batman in the DC
Universe Batman hush in Batman long
Halloween are movies that they're making
right now their animated movies there's
a trailer for Batman hush that's coming
at the end of March so of course I'll do
a video for that when it drops but now
thinking down the road when Justice
League Two finally rolls around and say
like four or five years the person who
plays Batman during that will probably
wind up being Matt Reeves version of
Batman they claim they haven't started
casting him yet but I'd be willing to
bet that they're looking at every single
male actor in Hollywood between the ages
of 20 and 35 maybe also a few bigger
establish a list stars on the older end
of that spectrum because the rumor is
that they're looking for a name
quote-unquote like an established actor
but he's also pretty young so just think
very young
Batman so let me know in the comments
who do you want to play Batman in Matt
Reeves movie because remember that
Batman is probably gonna wind up being
in the next Justice League movie down
the road there's a bunch more comic-book
stuff that happened this week I'll try
to get through all those videos as fast
as possible leave your requests in the
comments below
congratulations slow knee below knee or
the giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for my new avengers endgame
trailer video in post credits scenes and
click here for that new flash king shark
vs. Grodd trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]